[Music]
on this wednesday night a highly
anticipated approval
this is a momentous occasion health
canada green lights the pfizer biontech
coveted 19 vaccine
the geek in me is amazed when will the
first doses arrive and where will it go
first a bleak christmas ahead for
alberta covet 19 cases are expected to
overwhelm icus
will new restrictions make any
difference the promise of relief and
calls for help from a manitoba first
nation in crisis
and the pandemic forces small businesses
to think outside the box
it's taking every kind of creative force
we have to be able to keep the doors
open
the pursuit of profitability and
positivity
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
the first vaccine for covet 19 will soon
be on its way to canada
approval has been granted for the pfizer
biontech vaccine
and the first injections could happen as
early as monday
for weeks health canada scientists have
been analyzing data from the pfizer
biotech clinical trials
and it now concludes it meets the
department's stringent safety efficacy
and quality requirements
for use in canada the first dose is 30
000
shipped later this week from belgium by
the end of december 249
000 doses are expected and by the end of
march
4 million this makes canada the third
country in the world behind the uk and
bahrain to approve the pfizer biontech
vaccine
the american food and drug
administration is expected to approve it
tomorrow can you just explain to us how
you beat the fda
today um
sure we're just better in a year where
we haven't had a lot of good news
um this is a bit of good news and i
think we should take a a moment to
to acknowledge that and then we're all
going to get back to work
not everyone will get it right away
these first doses will go to 14
vaccination sites across the country
most canadians will have to be patient
and other vaccines are in the pipeline
for approval too
david aiken has our top story on
canada's first dose of optimism
this is a big deal mr speaker it is a
good news day for canadians
and now with health canada's okay the
first canadians will get
their dose of the pfizer biontech
vaccine within days
we have not compromised in terms of the
safety efficacy and quality
and then as soon as that review is done
we've done the authorization and we've
communicated with everyone and it just
so happened we got the last piece of
information
late last night health canada had been
waiting for the results of two clinical
trials
involving 44 000 people and even though
regulators used a new process
to quickly review those trials they say
no
corners have been cut it is a full
review in the sense that we looked at
the same type of data that we would
normally when we look at any vaccine for
authorization and while health canada
says the vaccine is safe
it also says there will likely be some
minor side effects
in the trials 84 percent reported a sore
arm where the needle was given
63 percent reported fatigue some
also reported headache or chills and
about 14
percent ended up with a fever after the
dose
so all of the reactions that we had seen
were relatively mild they were
short-lived
and then they resolved now to get the
vaccine into the arms of canadians the
doses are made in belgium
they will be flown on friday to germany
via ups
then onto a ups depot in kentucky
where the doses will be parceled out and
flown to one of 14
vaccination centers across canada with
first injections as early as monday most
provinces want those living in long-term
care facilities to be
first in line for the vaccine but since
many residents cannot come to a
vaccination center and
since pfizer does not recommend sending
the vaccine out
well something's going to have to give
there's some very i think uh
intense discussion and and the planning
going on for example
certainly the government of quebec for
reasons i can fully understand
say they would like to have their first
doses delivered in long-term care
facilities i think we can get that
up next a full dress rehearsal on friday
for the more than 100 federal provincial
first nations and health care providers
that will be the first to handle
canada's first
coven 19 vaccine donna
okay david aiken in ottawa thanks as
health canada's director of medical
science said today information is the
best antidote to any fears of the
vaccine
you can find lots of detailed
information and data about the approval
process for vaccines
and how the fizer biontech vaccine works
that's on the health canada
website lessons can be learned from the
uk too where thousands of people have
already received the pfizer biotech
vaccine
some people have had mild short-term
side effects like pain at the injection
site and fatigue which are not uncommon
with vaccines
two people in the uk both of them health
care workers with histories of severe
allergic reactions
did have an adverse reaction they have
both recovered but uk regulators are
advising people who have a history of
severe allergies
not to get the pfizer biantec shot
canada
is not going quite that far crystal
gomencing
reports that's it we're all done
day two of the rollout and now fewer
britons
may be able to get the pfizer biontech
covid19 vaccine
in what's being called a precautionary
move anyone with a significant allergy
to food
medicine or vaccines and carries an
epipen
shouldn't get the shot inevitably you
accrue more information
over time the information in this case
follows two national health service
workers having adverse reactions
both have a history of serious allergies
we know from the very extensive clinical
trials that this wasn't a feature
but if we need to strengthen our advice
now that we've had this experience
in the vulnerable populations the groups
who've been selected as a priority
we get that advice to the field
immediately
regulators also say the vaccine should
only be given where resuscitation
is available right now hospitals are
being used as vaccination
sites but it could limit more locations
being added
canadians will not see the same
limitations
instead a breakdown of ingredients is
being published on the government's
website
and people are encouraged to review it
dr mark greenwald calls the changes in
britain
ridiculous and that is not to protect
the public that's to protect
the individual's position the the the
authorities position to look good
they're warning you it's not known what
type of reaction the workers had
or if it was specifically caused by the
vaccine
but they're said to be recovering
meanwhile the vaccine campaign
continues but with nurses asking
patients about their allergy history
before rolling up their sleeves crystal
gomencing global
news london manitoba's premier expects
nearly 2 000 doses to arrive there
next week enough to immunize roughly 900
people
seniors those working in the health care
system and long-term care facilities
and indigenous people will get the shot
first
18 more manitobans died from covet 19
today
the province's second highest daily
death toll since the pandemic began
and 280 new cases were reported
in bc more than 600 new cases were
reported today and 16 more people
died bc's provincial health officer says
vaccine doses are expected there within
days
and the first to get vaccinated will be
4 000 front line workers
those working in long-term care homes
emergency rooms
and icus and next door in alberta nearly
4 000 vaccine doses will go to icu
doctors nurses respiratory therapists
and long-term care staff starting
next wednesday premier jason kenney is
rejecting criticism he waited too long
to impose tougher public health
restrictions
masks are now mandatory indoor and
outdoor social gatherings are banned
and bars and restaurants have to move to
take out and delivery only
as heather yurix west reports the system
is at the brink
right now edmonton's royal alexandra
hospital has become the epicenter of
alberta's fight against covet 19.
more than 100 covet patients are being
treated here
it's a very sick group of patients who
decompensate very quickly i'm on tonight
and i will not stop moving because they
can go from
just requiring some oxygen to incredibly
unweld very quickly
dr darren markland is welcoming
alberta's new measures
but he says this should have happened
weeks ago
the number of albertans in hospital has
already risen dramatically since the
beginning of november
when 115 people were in hospital and 28
more in icu
as of tuesday there were 542 in hospital
with 112 patients in intensive care but
according to internal alberta health
services modeling obtained by global
news by christmas eve the number of
covet patients could rise to more than
one thousand
with nearly 200 patients in icu what we
have seen
are the people in intensive care now are
likely the people that were exposed to
virus two to three weeks
ago when cases were about a thousand
and now we're closer to the two thousand
new cases
a day mark and these people will be the
icu admissions
around christmas time the jason kenney
government has been heavily criticized
for its delayed response
but the premier is making no apologies
so
why didn't we do this earlier because we
have
uh sought to limit the damage on the on
our broader society
and in an interview on edmonton's 630
chad radio the premier repeatedly
characterized criticism of his
government's response
as an affront to the entire province i
know there's been a fair bit of alberta
bashing here but alberta has actually
done albertans have done
remarkably well through the covet
pandemic until the last few weeks
that's classic jason kenny right is
finding enemies
much of the stronger criticism has
actually come from within the province
uh it has come from doctors it has come
from mayors it's come from the
opposition
uh it's come from the academic community
it's come from the business community
new measures won't bend the curve down
overnight the best hospitals can hope
for
is some relief in about five or six
weeks time heather urex west global news
calgary the crisis on a remote first
nation in manitoba is a stark reminder
vaccines are not here yet and the virus
is still spreading fast
more than 260 of the 1300 people who
live
on the shematawa first nation have now
tested positive for covet 19.
it is a remote fly-in community living
conditions are cramped
and the chief says his people need help
michael couture reports
seems that no one's listening
especially dustin trudeau the feeling of
being forgotten from a first nations
community
in northern manitoba sherry schweiter
lives in shimadawa
where one in five residents has kovit
19.
we do not have the supplies or the
machines
or the manpower to take on anything
like if it gets really out of hand
that's why shimadawa's chief and other
regional chiefs
asked prime minister justin trudeau to
send in the military
and airlift elders out of the community
it would seem there's been progress
we've heard the call for more support
and an evacuation of vulnerable
community members has already begun
with efforts underway to increase the
isolation capacity within the community
in a facebook post shamatawa's chief
eric redhead said military rangers are
assisting the community
a spokesperson for indigenous services
minister mark miller tells global news
48 people have been evacuated to
winnipeg
and that is key considering many people
in the remote community live in
multi-generational homes with little
room
to self-isolate opposition mps say the
government
should have been better prepared for
this we've been saying for months
that a worst case scenario would be a
covid hitting a fly-in
first nation with with limited resources
that is shamattawa now in addition to
covet 19 the community is also dealing
with a tuberculosis outbreak
and the water treatment plant keeps
breaking down
according to the manitoba regional chief
the canadian rangers have made that
assessment
and have indicated that
the water treatment operator is
currently
being isolated out of the communities
just another blow
to a community already dealing with so
much
mike liquiter global news ottawa
five mink on a farm in british
columbia's fraser valley have tested
positive for the coronavirus
the farm has been placed under a
quarantine order the facility hasn't
been identified but it's located east of
vancouver in the province's cobit hot
zone
eight workers there tested positive for
the virus this weekend
millions of mink have been called in
countries such as denmark spain
and the netherlands after a strain of
the virus was passed from humans to mink
and back to humans there are 60 mink
farms in canada
officials do not believe a cull is
necessary here
at this point the challenges of covet
19 vaccine delivery and distrust
coming up the hurdles ahead in the u.s
plus new clues in the mysterious illness
plaguing hundreds
in india
the u.s food and drug administration is
expected to approve the first covit 19
vaccine in the u.s tomorrow
cases are surging all over that country
and more than two thousand americans are
dying of the virus
every day once a vaccine is approved the
challenge will be
the logistics of delivering it and
convincing enough americans
to take it jackson prescott reports
if there was ever a time when americans
needed something to hope for
it's now on average a covet 19 patient
dies every 30 seconds in the u.s
an internal white house report shows the
rapid spread of the virus over the past
three months
the entire country now reports
staggering levels of new daily cases
things will be pretty dark i think
things will peak in
january and then we'll start getting
better
a vaccine is the light at the end of the
tunnel but there's a long way to go
the first few million doses there will
be minimal impact
on transmission itself because this is
not just enough doses to break
transmission
the white house turned down an offer to
buy more doses of the first
out of the gate pfizer vaccine
preferring to hedge its bets on multiple
different vaccines some still in
clinical trials
we have contracts with six vaccine
manufacturers that add up to
options to buy up to three billion doses
of vaccine
it will be late spring or early summer
by the time there are enough doses for
every american
even then there's no guarantee people
will take the shot
55 percent of new york city firefighters
surveyed said they would not get a
vaccine
a study from ucla found that two-thirds
of health care workers
those first in line want to delay
getting vaccinated
this was about this specific covid19
vaccine and that has to do with the
politicization of the process
that has to do with the the um the speed
at which these vaccines were developed
in a bid to boost public confidence
three former presidents
obama bush and clinton are volunteering
to be immunized on camera
while vaccine makers are distancing
themselves from the current president
hoping to avoid any perception that they
rush their products to market for
political purposes
with u.s regulators expected to grant
emergency use authorization to the
pfizer vaccine this week the first doses
could be coming within days
just as in canada frontline healthcare
workers are among the first priority
as they deal with that crush of covet 19
patients
donna jackson prosco
in washington thanks venice underwater
again
ahead why didn't the billion dollar
flood barriers work
[Music]
this wasn't supposed to happen again st
mark square in venice is under
water once more heavy rains and a high
tide led to this and a
massive eight billion dollar flood
defense system meant to hold back the
high tides
was not activated authorities apparently
didn't think the weather would be bad
enough
to cause this flooding just over a year
ago venice experienced its worst
flooding in more than
50 years officials in india believe they
may have found the cause of a mysterious
illness
test results show traces of nickel and
lead in a few blood samples taken from
some of the patients
since saturday more than 585 people in
southern india have been hospitalized
with an unidentified illness
their symptoms range from loss of
consciousness to nausea and anxiety
experts are now working to determine the
source of the heavy metals and how they
got into
the patient's blood farmers in south
africa are trying to save their crops
from swarms of locusts
this is very 2020 clouds of locusts have
taken over part of the northern cape
region
fumigation is underway to try to
eradicate them
in a single day a swarm of locusts can
devour enough food to feed 35 000 people
in january parts of eastern africa were
hit with one of the worst locust
outbreaks
in decades next canadians turning to
creativity
to try to stay in business
curbside pickup and takeaway or delivery
there are ways to shop local in the
pandemic
but a new survey by the canadian
federation of independent business shows
canadians only plan to spend a third of
their holiday budget
at small local stores competing with the
big guys
means having to get creative as abigail
beeman
explains this is great for people who
wear silver
when the pandemic closed the doors of
her business kim smiley opened a window
a lot of people are talking about how
they pivoted i like to think of it more
as
pure wedding her flagship store launched
just weeks before toronto's retail
shutdown
it was supposed to house her jewelry an
art gallery and be a space for workshops
about empathy
so now she offers personalized window
shopping sessions
door open or on the phone behind glass
at the customer's preference
i don't think we should give up on
beauty i think we should embrace beauty
and
people are shopping because it's light
right and people
need light right now because there is so
much darkness it's one thing to get it
online and
have it in a day it's another thing to
connect with people
in calgary new restaurant restrictions
were just announced
deja vu for the owner of modern burger
14
000 burgers over the closure which was
insane december is usually the most
profitable month for restaurants
not 20 20. stephen dear is focused on
curbside and
covid 19 pricing serving 795 burgers
we've done many things to make sure that
we're going to be
around for a very long time but speaking
for the general climate in calgary
it is the worst i've ever seen according
to the canadian federation of
independent businesses recovery
dashboard only 29
of small businesses have normal sales
but 43 percent of owners are working
significantly more hours
they're stressed both financially and of
course that feeds into emotional stress
as well
i'm definitely working in some capacity
seven days a week in order to stay
afloat and adjust
an online platform heather lee didn't
expect to launch a website when she
started her
gardening business in march but she
built one herself
she now offers online workshops
much more delivery and with no christmas
markets she launched her own
mini markets at coffee shops if i look
at it as a blessing rather a curse
i know that moving next year or the year
after into business that i do have all
of these other items in my back pocket
in a trying year all these businesses
trying to stay
positive and creative abigail beeman
global news
ottawa and that is global national for
this wednesday i'm donna friesen
2020 has been grim in so many ways but
one thing that has thrived apparently is
dating apps and not just for humans
these lonely otters who both lost their
longtime partners found love in lockdown
pumpkin and harris met on an otters only
dating app called fishing for love
they're now doing swimming lay in fact
harris has taken the big step of moving
from his sanctuary in cornwall
england to pumpkin's pool in scarborough
where he will be her
significant otter thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye